- [Interviewer] All right, Maria?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Maria, where
are you from originally?
- Mexico.
- [Interviewer] What part of Mexico?
- [Maria] Juarez.
- [Interviewer] Juarez?
- [Maria] Mm hmm.
- [Interviewer] Which is right
over the border from El Paso?
- [Maria] Yes.
- [Interviewer] And what brought
you to the United States?
- Hiding from people.
- [Interviewer] Hiding from people?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Really?
Who are you hiding from?
- From the mafia.
- [Interviewer] The Mexican mafia?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] In Juarez?
- Yeah, well, they're all connected, so.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, they're
all over, especially out here.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Tell me
something you experienced.
What kind of stuff was happening?
- Well, basically, they just, like,
well, this is why I ran
'cause I got tired of doing
what they want me to do.
You know, so it's like...
- [Interviewer] What age did
you get involved with that?
- 'Cause, um, I just needed, um.
- [Interviewer] What age were you?
- Oh, I was seventeen.
- [Interviewer] Seventeen?
- Mm hmm, I'm 52 right now.
- [Interviewer] What kind of
stuff were you doing for them?
- They were asking me to, like,
go rob the people, the girls, whatever.
That's why I got short hair.
I used to have long hair before.
- [Interviewer] Oh, so
you're kind of hiding?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] So in case,
they can't recognize you?
- Yeah, they're looking for a female,
and I, with this shit, yeah.
(Mark mumbles a comment)
(laughs) So, yeah.
So other than that, I just got tired.
I wanted to do me, you know?
- [Interviewer] Yeah, it's
hard to escape, right?
- Yeah.
That's why I'm,
last time we had an interview,
we couldn't, 'member, I guess,
'cause I can't stay still, I gotta move,
I gotta keep hiding.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
Is robbery the extent of
what you did for them?
- Well, yeah, I robbed,
I went in a house and did some damages.
- [Interviewer] How many
times did you do that?
- Uh, three times.
And then I had to slice some throats.
- [Interviewer] Oh, you killed people too?
- Yeah, I sliced it, sliced their throat.
I had to, I had to do it.
Either it was them or me.
- [Interviewer] Right. No, I understand.
Things were very, very
treacherous, vicious down there.
How many people do you
think you've murdered?
- Total?
Maybe like 18?
- [Interviewer] How many
years were you down there
doing that?
- How many years? Like maybe?
- [Interviewer] What age did you leave?
I guess is the question.
- Leave from that-
- [Interviewer] Juarez.
- Shoot, I been here like 13 years.
(siren blares in background)
- [Interviewer] Do you
have family at home?
- No, no kids, nothing.
- [Interviewer] No kids, nothing.
- Yeah, my mom's over there in Texas.
- [Interviewer] Can you go visit her?
- No, not really.
- [Interviewer] You can't?
- No, I can't. (laughs)
- [Interviewer] You're a (indistinct)?
- Yes.
So, not even by phone.
Put it like that.
So it's just...
[Interviewer] Yeah, I've
heard these things happen.
So you murdered people?
It wasn't necessarily
something you chose to do?
- No, I didn't chose to do that.
- [Interviewer] They
forced you to do that.
- Yeah, I was forced.
- [Interviewer] Is that something that you
have been there, like, repercussions from?
Just like knowing that
that's something that you did
and your responsible for somebody-
- No actually that's sad,
like, it didn't matter.
You could tell me to go
ahead and do anything,
and I'm-
[Interviewer] Really?
- Yeah, now it's like whole different.
It's 'cause you grow older.
- [Interviewer] It
doesn't really affect you.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] It's just a job you did.
- It's just a job, yeah.
- [Interviewer] That's interesting.
- Yeah, that's it.
- [Interviewer] So you're
on the run kind of,
you're in hiding now.
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Do you prefer this
to the life you lived down there?
- Well, yeah. (laughs)
- [Interviewer] No, some
people are born killers.
They just love it.
- Well, yeah. I used to
laugh about it, but, yeah.
- [Interviewer] Do you think
committing a murder makes it easier
and all the sudden you
get an appetite for it?
- I do.
I do. I get an appetite.
Like I wanna, like,
I get my anger, like,
it hits and I try to control myself
'cause I already know.
- [Interviewer] 'Cause you
know you're capable of-
- Right.
So, I try to walk away
or just bite my tongue.
Sometimes I just,
I sent a lady to a hospital
because I was so upset
where her eye almost
popped her eyes out.
Just my fist.
- [Interviewer] Well, I'll
try not to piss you off.
(both laugh)
What kind of precautions do
you take to not get caught?
You cut your hair.
- I cut my hair.
I just move around, different areas.
- [Interviewer] You use a different name?
- Yeah, of course.
I have to.
Like right now I just
came from Orange County.
I'm just everywhere.
- [Interviewer] You're
just running around.
- Yeah, I have to.
- [Interviewer] Wow, it's
such an interesting story.
When's the last time you
spoke to your family.
Your mother or-
- Shoot I haven't.
I haven't since I left.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
- I mean all I hear is like,
she's in the hospital,
but I can't get-
- [Interviewer] Do they know
that you're still alive?
- No. They don't know nothing.
- [Interviewer] They
think you might be gone?
- Yeah. They don't know nothing.
- [Interviewer] Wow,
that's crazy, isn't it?
- Yeah, that's kinda like messed up.
- [Interviewer] So you don't
have a social security card
in the United States.
You're just kind of like hiding out here?
Or are you a citizen and you
pay your taxes and all of that?
- No, I'm a citizen.
- [Interviewer] You are?
- Yes.
Yeah, I'm a citizen.
But I don't, I'm telling you,
I don't carry nothing with me
with my ID or none of that stuff, yeah.
- [Interviewer] You're as
anonymous as any citizen.
- Correct.
- [Interviewer] Wow, Maria,
thank you so much for sharing your story.
- You're welcome.
- [Interviewer] How many young people
do they recruit to do this kind of stuff?
- I don't know. As many as they want.
- [Interviewer] Really?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] So you
had friends who did this?
_ Yeah.
- [Interviewer] It's just
something you guys would do.
- It's just like that.
- [Interviewer] I mean, is it-
- It's just like a game, I guess.
- [Interviewer] Were you a troubled youth
before this happened?
Were you kind of like someone
who was getting into trouble
or drugs or violence?
- Well, yeah, when I was younger, yeah.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, you were.
(laughs)
So they're not picking
the A student from school.
- Oh no.
- [Interviewer] They're picking the kids
who are in trouble already.
- Yeah, or anybody.
I mean,
if they tell you, "Hey,
I need you to do this,"
with a gun-
- [Interviewer] So you're-
- Yeah, I'm gonna definitely do it.
- [Interviewer] And have
you had prison time?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Where?
Here in the United States?
- Yeah. Yeah.
Chowchilla.
- [Interviewer] What for?
- For armed robbery.
- [Interviewer] But
never murder or anything?
- Yeah, but (laughs)
it's a (indistinct).
[Interviewer] All right.
Maria, thank you so much
for your time today.
- [Maria] You're welcome.
- [Interviewer] And I'll make
sure no one can recognize you.
- Thank you. Thank you.
- [Interviewer] You bet.
Thank you for talking to me.
- Thank you